This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6-Mate English.
From BBC Learning English.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English, I'm Neil.
And I'm Rob.
What do you remember of your teenage years?
Oh, I was a nightmare.
I was rude to my parents, always stayed out late,
never did my homework, hung out with the wrong people,
and made lots of bad decisions. How about you, Neil?
Well, much the same, really.
People always say that about teenagers, don't they?
That they go through a period when they're out of control and behave badly.
But, apparently, it's not their fault, at least not directly.
So, who's fault is it?
Our brains, apparently.
Teenagers' brains are still developing in areas that control behaviour,
which could mean that you can't blame them for acting the way they do.
Before we find out more, let's have our question.
There have always been teenagers, but when was the word teenager first used
to refer to the 13 to 19-age group?
Was it A, the 1920s?
B, the 1930s?
Or C, the 1950s? Any ideas, Rob?
Well, I think it came along around the time of rock and roll,
so that would have made it the 1950s. That's my guess.
I'll have the answer later in the programme.
Sarah Jane Blakemore from University College London specialises in the workings of the brain,
particularly the teenage brain. Recently, she was a guest on the BBC Radio programme,
The Life Scientific. She explained that the understanding that the brain is still developing
during the teenage years is quite new. When does she say the first research came out?
The first study is showing that the human brain undergoes this very substantial and
significant development throughout adolescence in the 20s. The first papers were published in
the late 90s. Before that, and for example, when I was at university, the dogma in the textbooks
was that the vast majority of brain development goes on in the first few years of life and nothing
much changes after mid childhood. That dogma is completely false.
So, when did the research into the teenage brain come out?
Surprisingly, it wasn't until the late 1990s. This was when she said that the first papers on
this subject were published. Papers in this context means the results of scientific research which
are published. And she didn't actually talk about teenagers, did she?
No, that's right. She talked about the period of adolescence. This noun, adolescence,
is the period when someone is developing from a child into an adult. And it more or less is the
same as the teenage years. What I found interesting was that before the 1990s, people believed something
different about the way our brains develop. Yes, Professor Blake Moore said that the dogma
had been that our brains are mostly fully developed in early childhood, long before adolescence.
Dogma is a word used to describe a strong belief that people are expected to accept as true.
So, our brains are still developing much later than was originally thought.
What does this tell us about teenage behaviour? Of particular interest is an important part of
the brain called the prefrontal cortex. Here's Professor Blake Moore again. What excuse can she give
for teenagers who don't get their homework done in time? The prefrontal cortex is the part of the
brain right at the front just behind the forehead. And it's involved in a whole range of very high
level cognitive tasks such as decision-making and planning. We know that this region is undergoing
very, very large amount of development during the adolescent years. And so in terms of the
expectations that we place on teenagers to, for example, plan their homeworks might be too much
given that we know that the region of the brain that's critically involved in planning
is not developed yet. So, the prefrontal cortex is important in cognitive tasks. What are those, Rob?
A cognitive task is one that requires conscious thinking and processing, such as making decisions
and planning. It doesn't happen automatically. You have to think about it. So in the adolescent years,
this part of the brain is not fully developed. Note the adjective form here of the now we had earlier,
adolescence. So, this gives a good excuse for not doing your homework? I wish I'd known that.
I used to say that I'd left my homework on the bus or that the dog could eat in it. Now I could say,
sorry sir, my brain isn't developed enough for the cognitive task of planning my homework.
Yes, I'm sure that would work. Before we wrap up, time to get the answer to this week's question.
I asked when was the word teenager first used to refer to the 13 to 19 age group? Was it A,
the 1920s, B, the 1930s, or C, the 1950s? Rob, you said? I guess C, the 1950s.
And the answer is actually B, the 1930s. Very well done if you knew that.
Now a quick review of today's vocabulary. Adolescence is the noun for the period of change from
child to adult and the adjective is adolescent. This same word is also the noun for someone who
is in the teenage period. So an adolescent might be responsible for adolescent behavior in his or her
adolescence. Exactly. Papers is the word for published scientific research. Dogma is strongly
held beliefs that are not challenged. The prefrontal cortex is an important part of the brain which
deals with cognitive tasks. And cognitive tasks are mental processes that require active thought and
consideration, such as planning and making decisions. Well, my decision-making skills tell me that
it's time to finish. Well, your skills are working well, Neil. We may be going now, but you
don't need to. You can listen or watch us again and find lots more learning English materials
on our social media platforms. You can also visit our website at bbclearningenglish.com.
See you soon. Goodbye. Goodbye.